- When you see this show on the air,
it might seem pretty solid.
No mistakes, no stumbling on prompter.
Just perfection, really.
But yeah, I'm gonna be real,
it's not always that smooth.
Usually it's never that smooth with me.
Things go wrong here all the time,
and sometimes in the best possible ways.
Just look.
It's part two, and oh, what?
It's part two from an, oh (beep) fire.
Queen pins.
(Kelly mumbling)
Why?
Queen, queen, it's a weird word.
Okay.
- [Director] One, two.
- What, oh yeah, sure, oh (beep).
What's happening?
Why am I talking weird?
(Kelly mumbling)
Jennifer, and she what?
With new tech, oh, with new.
Now he's out with a new graphic novel
named hotel, or it's called,
named, what is it, a book?
Or it is, wait.
(audience laughing)
I'm tired.
I'm having a hard time.
I'm secretly eight years old
and your shoe farted when
you walked over here.
Hey, hey, hey.
(audience laughing)
Oh, I spit.
No I didn't covid police.
(Kelly burps)
I just burped.
That should not go anywhere.
I gotta pee, I gotta pee, I love you.
Thank you.
♪ Must have been hot ♪
Okay, I can't do it again.
I can't do it.
(Kelly laughs)
Okay, okay, okay.
(audience applauding)